okay welcome to the spoiler corner of
Philip Seymour Hoffman is a good guy and
the revolution has begun and Katniss has
no home and Peter's been captured yes
you know they're gonna get him back from
Jabba hunt with a Hut see this is the
umpires I may be a joke the bum reviews
too and I think again the twists and
turns in this are what keep this movie
from being a complete retread and a
waste of time and a bore and stuff like
that it's because it's constantly
building up this revolution is coming
and it's actually happening without you
even knowing it and that's so clever and
a lot of these left in the dark yeah and
and that that's what's gonna get - she
is kept in the dark she only sees bits
and pieces and and we're kind of kept in
the dark - and you could argue in most
movies they would do that
just to have a twist you know just to oh
but you didn't see that one coming but
they show so clearly that she is not
good at keeping the secret right here
that it's like when everybody's watching
you that she will break and she will
show the mercy and she'll act
differently and stuff like that that it
made sense for them not to tell her and
that's why I think this film works so
good is that the twist at the end is
100% justified that the Hunger Games
that Philip Seymour Hoffman is doing
this all to get them out of oh yeah at
the revolution and it's totally
justified remember this is this is a
tyrannical regime being run by crazy
Donald Sutherland he has to be able to
do this under Donald Sutherland snows
there's just no way she could know yeah
it because of his inter Donald summer
and then um not sénéchaux
what's-his-name blanking son of Seneca I
blanking i'm philip Seymour Hoffman's
character's name now the new game maker
um but he knows that snow has this
relationship with Katniss that he'll
talk to her that he's trying to feel her
out and watching her like a hawk and he
used to know have to suspect and when I
used his that distraction to his
advantage and he also knows that's why I
can't tell
Katniss because if he's watching her
that closely and picks up on anything
it's a brilliant play because this whole
movie is about distractions and the
destructive celebrity stuff and he's
just Drax the president because his eye
is on Katniss as well yeah destroy the
Nerdist and cast it game is that's why
as much as I didn't like the second book
cuz it's a retread I love the strategy
of and that's why when it entered the
Hunger Games I was the least interesting
cuz I'm like there is strategy involved
at the same time it's it's my right who
can I trust this and that figure out the
clock but it was that whole first half
that I love and there are clues there
there's stuff like people are trying to
make just a lot of tributes no they're
just trying to protect Katniss and you
catch on - - but you don't know why or
what its billing up to and it's done
much faster for my taste in the movie
than the book which I'm okay with
it's a very tight tightly adapted
screenplay which I appreciate I mean it
is long but the book was very
complicated - so I thought they managed
to really trim it to just what you
needed to give you a nice tight
narrative that works and I you know I
had a feeling watch I'm not gonna say I
do but I had a feeling that Philip
Seymour Hoffman was a good guy mostly by
his introduction to her sir I'm like
okay well a lot of this could be taken
as a double you know meeting amazed I'm
a good guy side um but I still wasn't a
hundred percent and I think this whole
movie star has that feeling like you're
not entirely sure what's going on or how
it's going you just know something is up
which is a great is always a good sign
of sequels or in a trilogy where you
have to get through that tricky area
it's like that was what I what I like
about you know the two towers Godfather
Part two Empire Strikes Back it's like
who you trust we're kind of on the run I
don't know what's going on it's upping
the tension so you can get to the finale
yeah I mean it's uh driving what else in
terms of doing it but those were just
the the strongest elements to me um it
was sort of modest James yeah what a
great scene that was the one great idea
that was the only thing in the book in
The Hunger Games part that I really
really enjoyed and I was like now that's
twisted that is
it's like let's have here your families
you know screaming for help and driving
you insane and no that's one of those
months I wanted to get a like yeah what
a well shots seemed yeah and I was
thinking like man what up just it's
genuinely creepy it's just a bad way
that was in the book that was silly in
the book and that's the weird thing
about the book there are some things
that are like really clever in the book
when it comes to the games and some
things I'm like really the the camera
dogs or whatever at the end of the first
book I was like what the hell is this
like and it's the same thing with the
monkeys like am i reading the same book
but I mean even in the game like you see
this there's fog coming and they have to
run away from it and you'll again what I
like is that saying like wow I gotta get
off this one I have no idea and then
when you see it hits some sort of wall
and it stopped and you're wondering like
what is that and then it's revealed and
it's it's even if you know the answer is
gonna come a little later you know or
shortly you're you're gladly questioning
it you're questioning it no I don't know
why I'm just glad they're alive
yeah no no you know what it is you're
gladly questioning it cuz you're you're
sure that you're in good hands and I
like I'm a movie where it's like I
suddenly stop critiquing it and I just I
say you know I'm in good hand I'm just
gonna let this take it wherever it takes
me and I know that there's something up
but I'm not gonna be the smartass and
try to figure it out I'm just gonna
enjoy it I like little movie can do that
well and I say you know I think the
disadvantage here's the interesting
thing and I'll say this about the book
disadvantage about both the book and the
movie when it comes in the hunger game
for shion's is the fact that we did it
before when I really think hard about
which I like better if you were to throw
both at me simultaneously I would go
with part two in terms of the both the
books and the movie I would go with that
second round of hunger games as more
interesting except for roo-roo was the
one thing in the first one that you
really had an attachment for and that
was brilliant you know and the ending
with Peeta was good but as an overall
games there's much better strategy
there's more interesting things going on
there's a lot more interesting stuff
going on in
second round of hunger games and
Catching Fire thought we didn't already
so I feel bad for punishing it but you
can't get around that fact I've been
there done that and had that version
actually been the only version I
probably say I love it
you know there's but because it's
redundant you know even though it's done
better I'm still like there's one other
thing I'll bring up here I show bran the
Bremen review but I'll say here is that
you know the depth of Roux in the first
one um it's a fact it gets the job done
I felt it's so much more in this one I
think they had this ingenious idea that
the technology of either you take a
picture it's sort of like Harry Potter
where you take a picture you film it and
they're just standing there you know
what I love about it is what it reminds
me of is those football snapshots of
your quarterback your linebackers when
they do they like the stats like now
let's see who's playing today like bring
up and it's one of those like pictures
where they're kind of still and just
looking at that and it is creepy yeah
and here and they totally use the
uncomfortableness because that is
uncomfortable we all see it during
football games uh and they totally use
that to make it look like she's there
staring at Katniss and it is so powerful
the family is right there you know it's
supposed to be looking you know proud
like yeah well it's all part of a good
cause and when she just sees room there
in canvas and I like to the actually
Pete up rates there he's not the one to
break it he's the one to break it first
and this is so effective to seeing her
stare and Katniss even though it's just
a picture anything just that painful
reminder that she's gone but it looks
like she's right there it's and this is
the difference I ain't picking on the
other director because I don't think he
did it Gabe
you can't do a gun I mean there are
really awful movies and awful directors
and this guy's know were even close to
that he did an okay job it's a very
difficult film to bring to the big and
he did have a very yeah it's it's a big
disadvantage of it's a very tough film
to bring to the big screen for a young
audience I think you 13 rating but this
is the difference between an okay
director and a great director because he
milked the scene he didn't even
have like he's just milking the
after-effects of it and it's more
powerful than what the other director
gave us which was a good scene I can't
even look it was like oh you botched it
yeah no it was effective but it was made
of service oh yeah this one it's just
like when you see her just looking I
can't just looking at the picture of her
just standing there it's just like oh
and then the family it's just like yeah
my god and it's not it's not quite
overkill it's just the right balance I
the guy who directed the first one you
know he's still got a lot ahead of him
and I hope he looks at it as like no I
didn't okay job and this was a learning
experience and I can go up from here and
but I don't even know who directed this
one like yeah buddy whoever got this one
just he just nailed it like and I don't
know what you know whether it's Talent
or just but like or lock but but boy
yeah both had a disadvantage going in
and that the first director had to bring
something very challenging and very
difficult to the big screen and keep a
pg-13 rating and still keep it emotional
this don't make a brutal this one had to
follow that with pretty much the exact
same story you know it again and shows
something that probably a lot of people
don't want to see because of that they
don't want to see the same thing again
and I think he had the heart attack and
I think he really overcame it and let's
let's be honest here this director also
had a couple advantages of he was also
saddled with a better script the first
script was not god-awful but it managed
to both add things which were really
needed and good which I believe Suzanne
Collins even added some things that help
giving you behind the scenes of the
games but I also left certain things at
alland it was kind of like if this
script was just so much tighter I just
didn't feel like there was any filler it
says like no I got a boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom and even for like two and
a half hours even though I felt like no
this is that really how long it was I I
didn't even feel I did I did feel it but
in the good wave like this is long but
I'll be damned if I'm not stay until the
I thought at the most two hours i-i've
already sure was closer to two and a
half
but bottom line if you do feel the
length you're glad to be in it that why
it's like watching for the cake yeah
well except for the ending it's like I
know it's long but you know what I'm
into it I'm just into it yeah I think
that's pretty much it for this boy I
said I will say this the that final shot
because she has to react to so much in
that final sudden like most of the movie
and she goes through like eight
different emotions of just like I want
to shut up I've been knocked out I'm
free
pitas been captured now I'm a leader of
a revolution that just slowly goes into
this like I'm gonna fuck you up like it
goes through all these things of just
like grief despair confusion to finally
just like vengeance and and it's so
perfectly done the last thing I'll say
just from a marketing standpoint is that
and it ends on the image of I guess with
every image of the bird it gets a little
closer out of the out of the circle and
this one you know but that's just like
the logo whatever that you have either
on the post or the book or something
like that this ends with the bird
holding the arrow and it's just after
you see the image you know your home is
destroyed she looks angry it cuts that
logo and you see it just break free and
go like this and the flyer and it's just
like nothing can get you more hive it
was so brilliantly done actually better
marketing for the next film that so
grant your emotion that scene is just
like totally a phoenix rising from the
ashes but it was like didn't x-men to do
that it was at three uh do why you see
the Phoenix in the water
brave looking like at the camera or
something it's feel like that shot was
done in one of the and that but not that
that there you see a little bit of the
Phoenix in the water buck or that
mountainous shit awesome yeah I think
this was really like effective like you
know okay it's shits going down you know
what's making me laugh though is we're
talking about the cult of celebrity and
the marketing and how and can be used
for evil and whatever you're good
hey guess what I'm like really we are
being just as fucking manipulated at the
end of this movie like there's an irony
here oh there is a great but being
entertainers it's like there there's
always pros and cons is - it's like one
there's there's a straight con of the
deception and that you have to sort it
is manipulating well solution being
entertainers that's why I appreciate the
evil in this movie so much because I'm
just like as totally what I would do
that's awesome and even on the good guys
cyber is like oh the dress oh I'm
pregnant like yeah yeah yeah we're
having a bit I'm like all of these
things are just like as an entertainer
Mike yes yes ratings reviewers lip view
what's the strategy of it - but what
what I like about what I think this film
or at least the good guys trying to do
and I think what hope we try to do - is
that we try to sort of play that
illusion we play the entertainment game
and stuff but try to get somebody else
to something good I'd even argue a lot
of politicians do that - but how long do
you play the game and how long do you
actually become the game and become part
of the province for my in my opinion I
think that ending scene is amazing as it
is is becoming part of the game because
their goals their goal really the
studio's goal could care less about how
good the story is and really the
director while he wants to tell a really
good story that's only part of it he has
to serve the studio so what does the go
get passes and the seats for the next
level but how do you do it you do it
through telling you gonna start that
people I see so it is about duty of the
Ballantine's but that last part I'm just
like yeah that's funny cuz that was all
about branding advertising the moment
building excitement teaser getting you
bad limbs like these are all things
we're decrying in the Hunger Games is
like oh man these people are so twist
but they all use focal I guess so
alright at least a good story so bad
about it like I said go see it man